1er mai fête du travail journée de
manifestations importantes en france
plus de 160000 français ont marché dans
les rues du pays dont pas 30 mail à
paris seulement des centaines
d'arrestations des dizaines de blessés
autant chez les manifestants que chez
les policiers
et malgré la casse à certains endroits
on dit tout de même que le pire a été
évité
il faut dire que les forces de l'ordre
sont mis à rude épreuve depuis les six
derniers mois avec le mouvement des
gilet jaune
nos collègues de bfm tv se sont penchés
sur la gestion de cette crise historique
par les autorités françaises dans le
documentaire police au coeur du chaos
j'en parle avec tata chariot
journalistes d' enquête pour bfm tv
elle fait partie de cette équipe qui a
réalisé pendant trois mois ça
documentaire voici un très court extrait
ce 1er décembre au soir après six
tentatives infructueuses
les forces de l'ordre parviennent enfin
à reprendre le contrôle de la tombe du
soldat inconnu
mais le monde entier découvre un pari au
bord de l'insurrection
239 départ de feu 412 interpellation 153
blessés
ces débordements ne pouvait-il pas être
anticipée
natation rios bonsoir bienvenue 24 60
je vous joins à bfm tv dans vos studios
alors que vous rentrez tout juste de
couvrir les grandes manifestations du
1er mai c'est le cas de le dire après
avoir été pendant trois mois au coeur du
carrosse de la police de ces grandes
manifestations du gilet jaune
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez assisté
à une sorte de test et le cas ou pas des
leçons tirées de ces grandes
manifestations dont on va parler dans un
instant travers votre documentaire dont
soir alors aujourd'hui oui effectivement
on a eu très peur les policiers les
gendarmes nous disait avant la
manifestation que ça allait être très
compliqué on attendait beaucoup de black
blocks notamment venus de l'étranger des
éléments très radicaux plus de 1500 et
en fait ça plutôt marcher dans le sens
où il y a eu peu de dégradations
aujourd'hui énormément de contrôle en
amont plus de 17000 contrôler beaucoup
de gardes à vue aussi le but c'était
d'empêcher la constitution de ce bloc de
ceux de ses black bloc et à priori ça
quand même relativement marché
aujourd'hui en tout cas ce soir pour ce
qui est du bilan
oui parce que on a vécu à paris et
ailleurs en france aussi comme de votre
documentaire la police au coeur du chaos
des débordements de part et d'autre à la
fois des casseurs et aussi de la
violence policière le gouvernement a
voulu instaurer une ligne dure n'est ce
pas avec de nouvelles nominations des
têtes sont tombées en cours de route
et aujourd'hui je crois que le président
de la cgt chez vous qui a dit oui je
sais ça j'ai senti la ligne dure du
préfet est ce exact
oui il ya des brigades spéciales qui
sont là vraiment pour interpeller pour
aller au contact qui d'habitude était
plutôt dédiés à des émeutes quand il
fallait gérer des émeutes par exemple
dans les banlieues françaises
c'était ces équipes-là qui était dédiée
bien aujourd'hui ce sont ces mêmes
équipes qui sont déployés sur le terrain
des manifestations
et c'est vrai qu'elle les utilise des
armes qui était peu utilisé pour du
maintien de l'ordre
ce ne sont pas des spécialistes du
maintien de l'ordre contrairement aux
crs et aux gendarmes mobiles du coup
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une bascule de la
part de la préfecture de police de paris
avec un nouveau préfet donc clairement
la ligne est plus dure que celle du
précédent en tout cas c'est la volonté
affichée par le gouvernement
nos téléspectateurs vont en voir
l'intégralité du reportage dans un
instant on vient de voir un excès
et qui se déroule à l'arc de triomphe
qui n'était pas protégée ce 1er décembre
sa pub vu d'ici ça nous paraît très
étonnant c'est l'os et les champs
elysées qu'il était donc de grands
débordements et vous avez appris votre
documentaire police au coeur du chaos
qu'est ce qui explique ce cas où là je
pense que c'est parce que quelque part
personne n'avait vu venir ce mouvement
ça devait être au départ concentrée sur
les ronds-points ce mouvement d'aidé
gilet jaune
et puis très vite les manifestations ont
pris de l'ampleur à paris et c'est vrai
que cette journée du 1er décembre a
vraiment marqué un tournant
les forces de l'ordre avaient
sous-estimé clairement le nombre d'
extrême présent de manifestants extrême
qui venait là pour rendre d'en découdre
et du coup effectivement il y avait des
forces très statique ils ont surtout
cherché à protéger l'elysée les lieux de
pouvoir
les champs elysées aussi parce que c'est
la plus belle avenue du monde mais
peut-être en omettant de protéger l'arc
de triomphe et quelques parler ils se
sont retrouvés bloqués ils n'ont pas pu
intervenir assez rapidement ils ont eu
beaucoup de mal à reprendre la main sur
les casseurs pourtant y avait beaucoup
de force de l'avarié de grand
déploiement
vous évoquez les casseurs commençons par
parler de cette violence elle était
alarmante cette violence on envoie des
extraits est très éloquent comment
expliquer que toutes ces forces de
l'ordre et unis n'arrivent pas à
maîtriser l'ordre à rétablir l'ordre
face à ces cas soient rasées black bloc
parce qu'on est face alors déjà on est
face à un phénomène très nouveau on
n'est plus dans les manifestations
autorisées déclaré donc ya pas de
parcours les forces de l'ordre savent
pas forcément où se positionner après on
est face à des éléments radicaux les
black blocks qui connaissent les
techniques pour se dissimuler pour
affronter les forces de l'ordre et puis
en plus de salles élément nouveau quand
même qu'elle a dans ce mouvement ce sont
ces gilet jaune qui sont devenus des
ultras quelque part ce qui augmente le
nombre de casseurs et ça ce sont des
éléments que les forces de l'ordre ont
mis du temps à voir venir et quelque
part le dispositif n'était n'était pas
adaptée ça n'allait pas assez vite
on nous a aussi beaucoup rapporter tous
les policiers qui étaient sur le terrain
était quelque part frustré parce qu'ils
voyaient ces événements se déclencher
devant leurs yeux et qui les attendaient
les ordres de la hiérarchie parce que
c'est très hiérarchisée tout ça remonte
jusqu'en salle de commandement la
préfecture de police de paris
mais que le temps que le dollar l'ordre
soit envoyée eh bien c'était trop tard
et il intervenait trop tard les groupes
de casseurs étaient trop mobile donc une
faille importante jusqu'à ce côté des
casseurs en même temps vous avez dans
votre document des policiers tu parle à
visage couvert et d'autres à visage
découvert qui quand même reconnaît ce
qu'il y a et on les voit aussi ses
violences policières là des abus
policiers
qu'est-ce qui les expliquent selon vous
alors c'est en tout cas leurs
explications à eux c'est aussi la grande
fatigue des policiers la grande pression
parce que c'est vrai qu'ils reçoivent
beaucoup de choses sur eux un des
cocktails molotov des clous et ses îles
les risques vraiment leur vie et ils
entendent aussi beaucoup d' insulte donc
forcément les nerfs sont mis à rude
épreuve
après on en revient aussi à
l'utilisation des armes le lbd qui n'est
pas destinée à être une arme anti
pour le maintien de l'ordre mais plutôt
d'habitude une arme anti émeutes du coup
forcément quand ya un élément qui bouge
c'est ce qu'on explique dans le
reportage c'est beaucoup plus difficile
de viser juste
ce qui fait que ça a conduit des fois à
des dérapages et des balles dans les
yeux des manifestants et des
manifestants éborgné après on le voit
d'autres d'autres dérapages ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des dérapages en tous
cas céder ce sont des coups de matraque
mais tout ça en fait dans un chaos
ambiant une ambiance très présente pour
les forces de l'ordre et du coup c'est
peut-être ce qui explique pour eux ces
dérapages alors tous n'accepte par le
terme de dérapages et de violences
policières tout c'est de toute façon des
enquêtes igpn la police des polices
françaises ont été sont instruites en ce
moment il faudra déterminer
effectivement si les policiers étaient
en tort à ce moment là on termina comme
à rétablir le dialogue avec les citoyens
français qui attend beaucoup de son
gouvernement et tout un maître dans
l'ordre d'une certaine manière c'est un
défi extrême pourrait conduire
complètement et c'est pour ça je pense
effectivement on a une révélation dans
ce documentaire c'est un haut gradé de
la gendarmerie qui lui nous dit là ce
sont des violences policières et en
faisant ça alors c'est que c'est
compliqué pour lui par la suite
d'ailleurs il n'a plus pu travailler non
au sein de la préfecture de police de
paris
le connaissent pas les colonnes du bo
depuis suite à la diffusion notre
reportage
mais je pense profondément qu'il l'avait
lui cette volonté de réconcilier la
population avec ses forces de police
d'avoir un discours très transparent
pour que justement une confiance qui
soit restaurée parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'incompréhension un manque de dialogue
on a beaucoup discuté avec lui et aussi
ça fait pas partie du reportage mais
c'est vrai qu'il nous disait que lui
pensait qu'il fallait plus dialoguer que
les manifestants ne comprenaient pas
toujours les charges des forces de
l'ordre et qu'il fallait beaucoup de
pédagogie en fait d'un chariot
journaliste à bfm tv avec des collègues
vous avez fait une enquête durant trois
mois sur à l'intérieur même dans les
coulisses pas du coup les mallettes
arrière au coeur même de ce chaos police
au coeur du chaos merci beaucoup la
tâche à rios au plaisir merci à vous
parle à nouveau au revoir merci au
revoir